[Musique]
bienvenue à fond là y est c'est ici que
marcel clémente et vit depuis son
enfance cette passionnée de la culture
martiniquaise aime particulièrement le
carnaval entre ses mains diables rouges
caroline vié lolli miniature prennent
vie en nous à les joindre les mains
sales clementé belle bonjour belle
bonjour moi au lac à son belleti croquis
son café l'aosis bombe apparemment qu'à
cause des bagages alors eh ben ça me
rappelle à ses angoisses
africaine et africaines talent pour
aller faire nos côtés et mariages
burlesques
j'ai eu beaucoup de nier ses deux neveux
qui chaque carnaval on venait me dire ça
tu fais ça pour moi qu'il faut habiller
tout comme ils ont grandi
ces gens là ne veulent plus de costumes
comme sa traditionnelle bon ben il
s'habillait comme ils voulaient donc ça
m'a donné l'idée de dire bon ben voila
je vais à billets des couples ça a
commencé comme ça ça doit faire mon dieu
ils ont tous une trentaine d'amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
semoun en pack avec pièce efforts pour
le fait qu'hosni mieux que limitées ou
annulées
et puis on craque oui allawi c'est pas
ça le carnaval m'expliquer c'est du
moment il allait manque allait encore
navale ou qu'à préparer sa despinoy
nouveau aux autres ni en charge du mardi
gras en temps lontan et bien adam sarlat
je sais quand on laisse les rênes du
carnage
c'est madame en n est pas tenu là j'en
ai jeté les faits comme un mal quand
même alors donc multi caps prend tout où
on utilisait un bac avant nous et on
doit lutter ni et tout ça jusqu'à couper
bâtiments souvent à moi et puis qu'à
coller en laye en est encore au bio
tenir robes longues et puis le cas
comiccon avant l'épisode à l'os et
magritte en rond et au
wavel on a notre camarade
c'est pour ça moi qu'à aller à danser
l'école a calé à danser association pour
monter haut
et en même temps mon cas constatés qui
s'est immolé la intériste
mignan huit chefs anouk en avalant csam
allait transmettre c'est du moment
la transmission et c'est ça
ouais
après les personnages de carnaval marcel
clementé veut confectionner des poupées
habillées en tenues traditionnelles en
selle bagua et cabaye balance élan
mouiller pouffant doc matinik